und dann saß ich da dann kann man auch
einer zu und er fragt dann so starr wie
abteilungsleiter
willkommen beim neuen video und zwar ich
habe eigentlich mehr so gedacht also ich
hab schon länger vor ort zu diesem thema
nimmt videos machen ihr habt ihr am
titel schon gelesen es geht so um die
jugend von heute aber so viele leute
schon ihre meinung gesagt und ich
vertrete die zum großen teil deswegen
wollte das eigentlich lassen allerdings
war ich dann letztes mal wieder auf
facebook unterwegs für jeden tag so ab
und zu mal ganz kurz und winter auf so
eine sache gestoßen dem ich dazu
verleitet hat alt doch ein video dazu zu
machen und ja ich weiß ich bin selber
eigentlich noch 17 also zähle ich auch
noch als jugendlicher dazu aber das soll
sich mehr so auf die 11 12 13 14
jährigen beziehen bevor wir jetzt dazu
kommen was ich da letztes gebunden habe
erstmal noch was anderes und zwar ich
habe überhaupt keine ahnung wie sich das
so schnell verändern kann ich meinen als
ich zwölf oder dreizehn war da waren wir
nicht mal halb so krass drauf wie
heutzutage
das geht überhaupt nicht mein kopf wenn
ich weiß warum geht das so schnell ein
beispiel wäre zum beispiel also ich war
letztens im freibad und neben mir saß
soll kreis von so weiß nicht design aus
wie neuen aber sollten vielleicht elf
oder zwölf gewesen sein und dann saß ich
da dann kann man noch einer zu und der
farc dann so wo ist die show ich so habe
ich das jetzt falsch verstanden was ich
suche hat gesagt also ich hab es mir
gedacht ich so was wird er nicht
verarschen
ich wusste mir zwölf mal was das ist ich
kannte das wort gaben das passt auch
überhaupt nicht meint ihr seht aus wie
neu und raucht naja hab ich erstmal so
hingenommen und dann war ich wie gesagt
auf facebook unterwegs und dachte mir so
eine scheiße ja ich will euch das ganze
mit ein paar bildern veranschaulichen
und sorgt dann dazu meine meinung
eventuell
ja so wie schon erwähnt ich war auf
facebook unterwegs und irgendeine hat
dann dieses profil geteilt und ihre
meinung dazu abgegeben
die meinung habe ich auch komplett
geteilt und ja wie ihr wahrscheinlich
seht es handelt sich um irgendeine
celine die s14 und schwanger und postet
alles dazu auf facebook und ist stolz
drauf ich mein ich finde es komplett
okay wenn man dahinter steht oder dazu
steht aber man muss das doch nicht auf
facebook teilen
und was da sonst noch abgeht mit ihr und
ihren freunden
das erfahrt ihr jetzt ja hier sieht man
auch mal ein bild von mir ich hab das
ganze zensiert ist meiner meinung nach
besser so sie soll ja nicht irgendwelche
schäden davontragen ja ich war halt
einen abend auf dem profil und hat mich
gut unterhalten vor allem auch dieser
text du könntest der prinz einer
prinzessin sein stattdessen bist du der
bass das ist nicht falsch geschrieben
einer [ __ ] ich geb nervig auf dich
meinung ich will jetzt auch überhaupt
keine auf julians blog machen aber ich
mache das jetzt einfach in diesem stil
weil es mir so halt besser gefällt und
auch glaube ich unterhaltsamer ist gut
kann man so schreiben den text muss man
aber nicht und vor allem nicht mit 14 ja
was ihr hier seht das ist das titelbild
von ihr
dort ist auch der freund drauf
vielleicht auch der vater von dem kind
ich weiß es nicht bei der wird mich
jetzt gar nichts mehr überraschen
auf jeden fall heißt der daniel oder so
und gut
daniel dann habe ich mal ein bisschen
weiter runter gescrollt und der adrian
kam ins spiel keine ahnung wer das ist
und der hat auf die seite von céline
gepostet
ich liebe dich da dachte ich so heißt
ein freundlich daniel weil sie hat auch
noch geschrieben ich liebe dich auch
okay vielleicht heißt der adrian daniel
man weiß es nicht kann ja auch sein
und dann ging es weiter kevin pascal
schöner name kommentiert viel glück
celine schreibt mainz tenet ernst von
daher eher soma klar warum sollte ich
nicht weil du was von mir wolltest
willst ich denen korb gegeben habe und
interessiert mich nicht bist eh voll die
drecks mutter hat ist er mit kevin los
ich dachte er meinte dass gerade noch
ernst erst so eine max macht mir
hoffnung und jetzt der deutschland
lebten
berlin wenn du das siehst du bist 14 man
das einmal im internet steht bleibt auch
im internet ich verstehe nicht wie man
sich so unterhalten kann man das mein
gott und dann kommentiert adrian halten
weil deine fresse junge deine mutter
klappspaten der junge komm mal klar
könnt ihr nicht normal deutsch schreiben
man wenn ihr das in zwei jahren lest ihr
schämt euch wie sonst was wirklich man
junge alter du bist so harten nur weil
ich dir einen korb gegeben hat braucht
jetzt zu mir zu kommen als die alte
daniel sicher dass die dem in korbach
unbedingt ein vaterschaftstest das
empfehle ich dir das ist jetzt wirklich
gut ja gut wenn euch das video gefeiert
wenn ihr vielleicht öfter bock darauf ab
dass ich das so in diesem stil mache das
auf jeden fall noch urlaub und mich
freuen schreibt noch mal eure meinung zu
dem ganzen thema in die kommentare
wie ist das bei euch ist das krass mit
wie vielen fängt man an zu rauchen
45 instagram snapshot dass eine band
oder unten in der beschreibung hier oben
links geht's weiter mit dem s video das
war die flache stellen steckt das auf
jeden fall mal ab wir sehen uns nächsten
montag wieder 15